atemberaubend schön und doch bitter arm
das ist nepal kulturelle reichtum aber
kaum sauberes wasser und mittendrin der
schweizer reggae-musiker dodo was viele
doch wir zeigen sein großes abenteuer
zwischen chillen jam & charity
willkommen im alltags chaos von nepals
hauptstadt kathmandu motto ist
angekommen und versucht sich erstmal
zurechtzufinden treffen mit den
freiwilligen helfern des hilfswerks viva
con agua dieser sammeln in der schweiz
an musikfestivals spenden für
wasserprojekte mit dem verkauf seines
hippie busses hat otto hier kräftig
beigetragen
auf der fahrt durch kathmandu wird ihm
klar dass infrastruktur ist in prekären
zustand nach dem zerstörerischen
erdbeben im vorjahr gibt es noch viel zu
tun
durchs ziel herausfinden wo seine spende
hin fließt und mit lokalen musikern
auftreten
dazu trifft er einen der gründer von
viva con agua aus hamburg das prinzip
des hilfswerks über die musik spenden
generieren um möglichst allen menschen
zugang zu sauberem wasser zu ermöglichen
lebensaufgabe
zurück im hotel porto probt mit seiner
musikalischen begleiter marco jäger die
ersten kontakte zu lokalen musikern sind
geknüpft
doch die umstände zum german sind prekär
so plagt eine hartnäckige erkältung und
immer mal wieder fällt der strom aus
und das loslassen lohnt sich denn die
aufnahmen mit den lokalen musikern
werden zum magischen momenten doch nutzt
da der europäer seine spender rolle und
billig musiker an land zu ziehen
musikalische künstlerische wanderer bis
wann sagt befehl wenn wir das großstadt
ich möchte ich die babys aber ich muss
immer sage ja ich weiß noch nicht wie
das der nutzer um das ist wenn es abend
ihre
berauscht von den verführerischen
klingen rein in den ganz eigenen sog
dieser stadt wo alles irgendwie
aneinander vorbei läuft
das letzte
dschibuti
das muss liebe nutzer ob es gelingen
zu jedem traum könnte das hoch gezogen
die abreise zu den wasserprojekten steht
kurz bevor
lotto gibt ein kleines aufwärm konzert
für sein schweizer hilfswerk publikum
so
denn bis tief in die nacht
doch wirkt otto genug fit sein für die
beschwerliche reise in die abgelegene
dörfer im süden nepals und fließt das
geld in die richtigen projekte
das sehen sie in der nächsten folge